es ist krieg in europa und die
bundesregierung will schwere waffen in
die ukraine schicken und plötzlich
verschwindet deutschlands wichtigster
panzer manager spurlos es ist ein krimi
um thorsten kurz der geschäftsführer von
rheinmetall bereitet eigentlich gerade
die lieferung von 100 mader panzern an
die ukraine vor gilt laut
verfassungsschutz als geheimnisträger
plötzlich lässt termine platzen tauchte
einfach nicht mehr auf
das mysteriöse verschwinden des
rheinmetall managers thorsten k bild
chefreporter nikolaus harbusch
recherchierte die hintergründe zu diesem
fall wer ist der manager der plötzlich
spurlos verschwand er ist chief
operating officer und geschäftsführer
von rheinmetall
er ist derjenige der gerade die 100 mara
panzer für die lokalen vorbereitet all
das läuft bei ihm zusammen thorsten k
ein wichtiger deutscher rüstungsmanager
zuständig für die deutschen maler
lieferungen an die ukraine
ausgerechnet er verschwindet plötzlich
dieser mann erschienen vergangenen
donnerstag nicht zu einem farbigen
dienst geschäft und da ist der sonst
sehr zuverlässig in diesen dingen an
versuchte ihn zu orten das war nicht
möglich sein handy war abgeschaltet in
kassel sind die rheinmetall landsysteme
gmbh laut ermittlern war der manager mit
einem roller zu einer sparkasse gefahren
doch dann verliert sich die spur
zufall oder eine gezielte
geheimdienstaktion die überragende
nachrichtenlage moment ist der lokalen
konflikt und ein manager der sich hier
einbringt der ja eine der kriegsparteien
anzahl zur verfügung stellen will dass
der ins fadenkreuz
russischer dienste geraten kann das ist
klar das dauert der vier tage bis eine
funkstreife in einem abgelegenen gebiet
in der nähe der kasseler messehallen in
einem auto fand er war eine sehr
schlechten gesundheitlichen zustand von
der sparkasse in kassel wo ihn eine
überwachungskamera filmte bis zum
fundort sind es vier kilometer
gefunden wurde der manager aber erst am
vergangenen sonntag in einem pkw ganz
offenbar hat er substanzen oder alkohol
verabreicht bekommen oder selbst zu sich
genommen da sind die ermittlungen unklar
ein wichtiger deutscher rüstungsmanager
der plötzlich spurlos verschwindet
das klingt nach einem spionagethriller
im jahr - kreisen heißt das dass waffen
manager grundsätzlich sehr gefährlich
leben und deshalb oder auch in alle
richtungen ermittelt weder die behörden
noch rheinmetall machen weitergehende
angaben zum gesundheitszustand oder zum
aufenthaltsort von dem manager thorsten
karl lebt aber was wirklich mit ihm
passierte müssen die weiteren
ermittlungen zeigen der fall bleibt
vorerst ein rätsel